So I want to share with
you a story of evolution.
And as you can see, this
evolution, unsurprisingly,
starts at sea.
See, this is me.
And I just started
out my master's degree
in Marine Ecology and I
went out to the Red Sea
to do some fish sampling.
And when I was there,
I was completely
overwhelmed by the
beauty of the coral reef
with all these
beautiful shapes, colors
and really nice looking fish.
But when I was done
sampling and looking
at all these crazy fish
and it was time for me
to go in and fill in the data.
I was welcomed by this ugly,
unintuitive, hard to navigate
Microsoft Access forms.
And this is the starting
point for our journey.
This journey is a
walkthrough of how
I moved from using Microsoft
Access to using Google Sheets
and using R to do our own
lab custom-made database.
And I hope that
whether you're using
Microsoft Access
now or Google Sheets
or any of these
different alternatives
for making data forms,
you will find some lessons
that I've learned,
something that you
could use in your workflow.
So the first step
in this walkthrough
was to understand our needs.
And to understand
our needs, I just
have to say a few words
about how exactly we operate.
So we are, as I said,
a marine ecology lab
and we are going
using scuba diving
to do some underwater surveys.
So we go out there, as you can
see here, with a water resistant
piece of paper and a pencil.
And we just do some
records of the fish
species and their abundance
when we are underwater.
So why do we need--
Why did we need Microsoft
Access to do that?
So first we know we
needed a big data set.
So as you can see
from these photo,
these are taken
several years apart.
We are doing this
for a long time
and we have no intention
of stopping anytime soon.
And you can see why.
Another thing, we need a
strict--for our database--
we need a strict form
of data validation.
Because this fella.
Their name is Pomacanthus imperator.
And if you don't write that
exactly as the bottom row,
you're going to have a lot
of problems down the road.
And that's true for
any of the cells
that we have in our data form.
Most importantly, we
need relational data.
So our data is structured
in a relational format
where we have the trip,
the topmost level is
mainly the location
where we are diving in
the world, and the date.
Then we have the site
which is more close
up of who is diving where
exactly in the actual dive
site.
Then we have the transect, the
underwater environmental data.
So that's the visibility,
the depth, the substrate.
Lastly, we have the observation
itself, the species of the fish
and its abundance.
When we used Microsoft
Access, unknowingly,
we made some sacrifices.
So first we had really
bad user interface.
So for us, it was really hard
to work with Microsoft Access.
I remember clicking the
wrong button a few times,
getting this really
loud error message.
It was a hell to, at least
for me, it was a hell to work.
Another thing that was really
detrimental to our workflow
is that we couldn't figure out
how to do simultaneous data
entry for our needs.
So what happened is we had
to actually email the database
file from one person
to another, and so we
took turns filling in the data.
So sometimes it could
take more than a
week until it was
your turn to do so,
and it was really detrimental
to the quality of the data.
Lastly, since we didn't
build the database ourselves,
it was really hard for us to
make any customization needed
for our needs.
So for example, we are working
on both the Mediterranean Sea
and the Red Sea.
They are completely different
seas with completely different
animals.
We need different protocols.
And for this we need
a different database.
So that was also a problem.
Taking into account
all of these things
we set out to create
our own database.
So what we did was we create.
So that was our prototype now.
Okay, we have this giant
Google spreadsheet
for an entire expedition.
And every day we had someone
in charge of manually creating
different spread
different worksheets
within the spreadsheet,
different works,
different worksheets for each
of the different surveyors
of that day.
So when I created this
Google Sheet prototype,
I needed to take some
drastic measures.
So I won't have any user error
and didn't know how to do that.
So my first idea was to have
this really horrendous color
coding.
And I'm going to show you we
had this bright red trip data.
So these are different forms.
All the forms are
in different colors.
So we have this
trip data in red.
Then we add this
yellow, is it yellow
here, this yellow site data,
the green transect data,
and lastly, that
blue observer data.
So as you can see,
really nice colors.
And to connect this--to
connect all of these,
the observers themselves
had to copy and paste IDs
so we could create
this relational data.
But then, so what happens
is for every expedition
we have this: a lot of
different worksheets
within a spreadsheet that, as you
can see, some red, some blue.
It's a whole mess.
But this is where we
used googlesheets.
It was googlesheets
at the time,
Now it's googlesheets4.
We could
read by that color coding.
So, and then using that
ID that the users had
to copy and paste,
we could use dplyr
to connect it all to a flat
data set that we can work with.
Now, I know it's a mess.
And if you have this, if you have
this expression right now, then
yeah, this is the expression
that all my colleagues
had when I presented that
idea and I told them,
let's stick with it.
It can't be worse than
what we currently have.
It wasn't worse.
But the thing is, it
doesn't have to be perfect.
All right?
So, this is us.
This is crit 2019.
And I know it doesn't
look like that,
but we are currently hard
at work filling in the data.
So as you can see, we're
doing that together.
So that's an important thing.
We managed to solve
one big problem, which was
the simultaneous data entry.
So now that we can work
online, as you can see,
it's the blue one.
So,
once we manage to
solve this problem
and I know that the
prototype works,
it's time for us to adjust, to
make the necessary adjustments,
to make this data form database
much better to work with.
So how did we do that?
Mainly by increasing our
dependency of googledrive
and googlesheets4 package.
So we have a great tool
for actually working
with Google Drive
and Google Sheets,
and we managed to automate
the entire process.
So what we did at first,
we had an offline file
that replaced that old
yellow and red worksheets
that we had. Now they
are offline.
And from this, we can set out
to automate the whole thing.
And we use googledrive for
the housekeeping and navigation,
and for the manipulation
we used googlesheets4.
More specifically,
we had drive_mkdir()
to create individual folders
for every sampling day.
So now instead of having one
big Google Spreadsheets that's
just somewhere on Drive,
we have this hierarchy
when we have an
expedition directory
and within it for each day
we have a different folder.
So it's much more organized
and gs4_create(), this function,
we used to upload that
offline file from which
we create the metadata.
We use drive_find()
and drive_cp() in order
to copy and paste
pre-existing templates
that we had to today's folder.
So then we use sheet_copy()
and range_write() in order
to manipulate those
pre-existing templates.
(bless you) to manipulate
these pre-existing templates
into whatever's
necessary for today.
So change in site
numbers, hour, et cetera.
Lastly, what
I really liked
is that we have
drive_share() and we
use this function
in order to send out
specific email
for specific users
so they can only
change their own data,
so they can only fill
out their own form.
And it's really good because
they don't have to mess around
with anything in the database.
And they can't accidentally
erase or change
someone else's data.
And for them it's really easy
because all they have to do now
is get an email and they
sit down
and they fill out the forms.
So this is what we get.
This is a folder for a
day and we have the metadata
up there.
And as you can see, we have
individual spreadsheets
for each of the
different observers.
And in order to do that,
I had to be
be creative in a way.
And let's zoom in into
one of the spreadsheets.
So first thing as you can see,
the colors are much better.
They're not really
bright anymore.
And I wanted to have a
great, a strong connection
between the environmental
data and the fish data.
So we're doing ecology,
which is basically
the relationship between a
species and its environment.
So we wanted to have this
demonstrated in our database,
in our forms.
To do that,
you can see columns A and B
don't follow the same logic
as columns C through H, which
some people would say
is unorthodox and incorrect.
And for those of you who
can't see that A and B,
each row does not
represent an observation.
It is a long format.
But once you realize that you
can go from this long format
into a wide format, fairly
easily using the tidyverse,
then it opens up a whole world
of possibilities for you.
For example,
on another project where
we do quadratic sampling.
I managed to take the
exact piece of paper
that surveyors go to [in] the field,
and I managed to copy it almost
verbatim into a digital form.
Making the transition
from the actual survey
data from the actual real
world data to the digital data
much more intuitive
for my users.
I encourage you
all to think about how
user-oriented your data
forms are at the moment
because I know, I've been taught
as well, that you should make
your data as computer readable
as possible for analysis,
visualizations, et cetera, but
at the same time, all of us
were taught how easy it is
to manipulate the data shape.
So we could all stand
to benefit from having
more user-oriented data.
So we could then get, so we
could minimize the errors
from those users because it will
be much more intuitive for them
to fill in the data forms and
it will make our data much
better at the end.
So, this was our project.
This is how it went
for quite a while.
This worked quite well.
It was really automated
and we worked for two years
or so on this type of forms.
But as we continue
to use this, we
realized that we need to
make additional changes
because as we kept
using this database,
so did our needs and
our needs change.
So we realized that
having an offline file
was creating a bottleneck,
because we needed
to have someone
who knows exactly
how to type in the
specific observer's
name and all kinds of stuff.
Then we decided to put
that on the cloud as well.
And then using the googlesheets
gs4_browse() function,
we can open up the browser
directly from RStudio
and then it opens up
something like that.
and then you just fill
in with that validation,
you fill in who are the
observers for today?
So as you can see, I
took this opportunity
to thank all my colleagues
here and my collaborators
whose feedback was really
what drove this thing forward.
So while I did the coding
and I presented the idea
and everything,
their feedback is
what drove this thing forward.
If it wasn't for
them, we would still
be stuck in that ugly
color phase, honestly.
So thanks for that.
Another thing, since we built
this thing from the ground up,
now it's really easy for
us to make adjustments
whenever we need.
So, for example, let's say
we have another project now
we just have a template,
change a few lines of code,
not even change,
we just add a few lines
of code, and we now
have a whole new database
for another project.
Really easy to work with.
So basically, we can do
whatever we want using
googlesheets4 and RStudio.
And now it's even more
automated in a sense
that you just run
one line of code.
For example, here
you select
What kind of projects
are you working on?
Fill in the data, like the actual
observer data, and just
here, as you can see here,
also, you just confirm
that it's correct
and then R does
anything for you.
Everything for you.
You can take a few
minutes, make some coffee,
and then you spend the afternoon
filling in data with your friends
together and colleagues.
So, this is us
enjoying filling data.
As you can see, we
really like our job.
I hope this convinced
you on the power
of using R right from the
start of the data manipulation
stage.
I mean.
Right from where we're actually
getting the data.
If you
If you want to explore this
option of having a more custom
made database, some
things to consider.
So the first thing,
consider what exactly do you
need out of your database?
Think about whether you are
currently meeting your needs
or are you simply over-
killing your needs with what
you are doing right now.
And in order to
meet those needs,
don't be afraid to be creative.
Right, if you data needs,
if you need a triangle-shaped or
pyramid data, you can do it.
Don't be afraid to pursue the
type of data that you want.
Lastly, pay attention to
whatever your users' feedback is
and make sure to keep moving
forward with whatever project
you are currently working on.
And if you want
to see how we keep
moving this project forward
or you're interested in code,
trying to replicate this
for your own needs,
then you can go
to our GitHub page
and I'll make sure to upload
the slides as well to GitHub.
And if you have any questions.
I'm free.
I'm willing to help and
Thank you for listening.